un cadeau symbolique pour le premier
anniversaire de l'invasion russe à
grande échelle en Ukraine cet avocat et
activiste serbe et déterminée à faire
entendre son message malgré les barrages
de police qui protègent l'ambassade de
Russie
voilà ce qui se passe en Ukraine
c'est la conséquence de leur politique
le résultat de leur agression
et ça continuera à s'amplifier à moins
que le régime de Moscou et toute la
Russie ne soit vaincu
les boutons pas belgin à quelques mètres
de là ils sont des centaines descendus
dans la rue pour afficher leur soutien à
l'Ukraine une démonstration plutôt
inattendue dans ce pays ami de la Russie
qui a toujours refusé de se joindre au
sanctions occidentales en Allemagne
c'est en exposant ce char détruit dans
les combats keno veut interpeller
l'opinion
les gens pensent que les chars sont
invincibles et le fait de les voir
exploser vous montre qu'ils ne le sont
pas et que la guerre n'est jamais une
bonne idée alors ne la commençait pas
détruit près de bout de chat en mars
2021 le char sera exposé tout le week
end
autre image forte à Londres devant
l'ambassade de Russie ou des centaines
de litres de peinture ont été déversées
au sol laissant les voitures dessinées
le drapeau ukrainien sur la route
à travers le monde les marques de
soutien se répètent de l'Australie à la
Thaïlande en passant par Israël
au même moment en Russie les tentatives
de soutien à l'Ukraine sont rapidement
stoppés
comme ici à Moscou ou cette femme est
arrêtée par la police après avoir tenté
de déposer des fleurs devant un monument
l'honneur d'un écrivain ukrainien